طبعا نذهب مباشره نستمع الى وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
ايضا صواريخ معترضه لصواريخ الروسيه بينما
يسمى الكرمله بقصف شكرا
وصل الى
18.6 مليار دولار
منذ بدايه العدوان الروسي
وهذا ما ساعد اوكرانيا على استدامه
قتالهم وهذا يوسي
مجموعه الاتصالات
مع الدول الاخرى ذات النوايا الحسنه
دول
لحمايه الاطفال ورجال
والنساء الاوكراني الى الابره الامريكيه
وهولندا والجمهوريه تعملوا معانا
ايوه اثنين وسبعين اريد ان اشكرك
الوزيراني
وموظفهما
وهذا الجهده سوف يعزز من هذا التوجه
مجموعتي الاتصال
القوات المسلحه الاخرانيه
الرئيسيه الاتصالات
وسوف نلاقي شو موضوع تدريب وتجهيز القوات
المسلحه الاوكره الى الدفاعي عن بلادهم
سوف تستمر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاساسيه
هذه المحادثات مهمه
بحاجته همم الخاصه
بالفعل حافيه
التقدم نحن الهمنا صمود الشعب الاوكراني
ومجموعه الاتصال وجهودها فقد اظهرتم
تعزيمه لمساعدته اوكرانيا لدفاعي من اجل
الحريه والدفاع عن النظام العالمي القائم
على القواعد الذي يؤمنون جميعا شكرا جزيلا
جميعا لالتزامكم بهذه القضيه
كانت اذا هذه الكلمه لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن متحدثا عبر الفيديو
في هذا الاجتماع
اجتماع مجموعه الاتصال الدفاعيه الخاص
باوكرانيا وتحدث عن استمرار الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في دعم اوكرانيا في هذه
الحرب الروسيه عليها